My name is Winjand
A P van Tilburg
and I work at King's College
London in the psychology department.
One version contained an author
with no middle initials.
The other versions had one,
two, three or four middle initials
instead. And what we found was
that students liked this written work
better if the author had more middle
initials - even though the exact text
of the essay was the same.
This is something to do with
the stereotypes that people use -
so because people with
middle initials are seen as more
prestigious, people automatically -
but incorrectly - assume that their
work must therefore be of a
higher standard.
Thanks for watching. Don't forget to subscribe
and click the bell to receive notifications for new videos.
See you again soon!